what are you doing in your spare time
are you gaming are you what are you
watching now on Netflix what are you
doing in your spare time for fun man
outside of being creative and making
music Superman son look playing the game
man definitely I like playing the game I
like to be Rock I like to really like
I'm a real like nature type guy you're
gonna say I'm a Nature Boy I feel like I
get a lot of my material and [ __ ] from
nature so what are you doing like you go
out to the [ __ ] force in case I like
to watch like you both saying like I
octopus and [ __ ] you know what I'm
saying like did you see you like to
watch octopus octopus
you ever see uh that the octopus escaped
the boat yo man [ __ ] octopus are like
alien life form they're so smart yo you
think I'm saying you phone me my mom be
just on other creatures and like she'd
be watching like YouTube videos no
whales and [ __ ] you told me I had a
dream I was with a well word up out of
out of the world that [ __ ] was crazy
actual whale actual not a BBW just the
actual well yeah I had a couple of those
too you know